to the haters don't think porn is a real
job I mean I can tell you what my
business partner would say he would say
well we employ people do they employ
anyone did they give the you know like
do they bring back into the economy and
load up like he's very he's very gung-ho
about that but I think I'm more of a
pacifist I don't really like upsetting
people
I guess at the end of the day I don't
really mind if some people don't think
it's a real job because it won't stop me
doing what I'm doing and I take it as a
real job and I do it very seriously and
that's enough for me
[Music]
[Music]
I do think there's a healthy and
unhealthy weight of youporn
I think porn is like any other
indulgence like chocolate or alcohol you
should have in moderation you should
have it to a healthy standard some
people they watch too much of it or they
get too obsessed with it and it becomes
unhealthy and that's not a porn thing
that's a human addiction the vice thing
and I noticed that with some people that
do obsessively watch it it that do get
into it you know they watch so much of
it they become desensitized to it in the
same way that you can become immune to
well not immune but you know you can
become more tolerant of alcohol so you
have to consume more and it's the same
for porn so you know like suddenly
watching vanilla stuff doesn't get you
off anymore so you want to like you you
personally progressively start watching
harder stuff because that's what you
need because you consume so much of it
my family and I actually moved around
quite a lot because of my dad's job so I
think I've been to about 10 to 15
different schools around that time which
is a lot and so I was very shy and very
awkward and I Comfort ate a lot so I was
quite a bit chubbier than I was I think
the biggest size I was went up to a size
14 which you know on an Asian person it
was very very strange so I I wasn't very
good at making friends and I kind of
went into that emo edgy phase and I had
like the fringe and I dyed my hair I had
these really big glasses and braces and
basically you know I didn't I don't
think I was very approachable
and then I kind of went in into myself
more because no one approached me and
then I'd be like well I didn't want
friends anyway and I read more books and
I spent all my free time at the comic
book shop I was very much in a geek type
but way before I was popular
I like I'm really happy now that people
love comic books and it's really cool
but it wasn't cool when I was at school
and I really wished it was because I
might have had friends Ben
when you go through not being popular
and you kind of you kind of become
defensive about it you're like okay well
no I'm not going to follow fashion
trends that's so basic and you know I'm
not doing this because I choose to and I
was working and my housemate was like oh
by the way I read it and I I follow some
Asian forums John do you mind if I just
post a picture of you when I was like
yeah whatever do that I don't care
and then he posted this picture it was a
really terrible picture and I wasn't
really positive comments are like oh
she's cute and I was like oh someone
said I was cute and then I started
posting more pictures and they got
progressively more like revealing just
because I was feeling very confident the
time I was like yeah I'm feeling good
about myself and that whole thing you
know it made me start wanting to be
better like I did start paying attention
to my looks and I did start looking at
makeup tutorials and just in general you
know that a little bit of that boost and
confidence really makes you want to help
yourself it's not like I wanted to
change for them it's just like I wasn't
I obviously wasn't happy with my looks
back then and then I was just like you
know what it is okay to try and I think
part of me didn't want to try before
because you think oh what if I try
really hard and I'm still not why do I
still get rejected and stuff so it went
from posting pictures and just
interacting with people like replying to
post comments and then someone's like oh
why don't you try coming and I was
taking so much time talking to people
through comments it made sense to just
talk to them for real time and coming
with so much fun and again confidence
increased and blubber gleb and people
like oh you should make some videos and
I was like yeah I could do
[Music]
I've heard the argument or the complaint
saying porn is so bad for children
because children are learning about sex
and relationships in porn and I'm just
thinking if your child has to resort to
watching porn and this is their only
knowledge of sex and they learn sex from
that then you at some point have done
something wrong because you should have
had a conversation with your children
and you should they should know what a
healthy relationship both you know
normal and sexual is that they can look
at porn and they can realize this is
fictional this isn't this isn't how real
relationships are because at the same
time you know your kids can watch films
with explosions and killing and they
don't think oh yeah that's just how
people live yeah it's totally okay to
just go around stabbing people they
don't think that because you've taught
them way before then that no murders
wrong so why why why do you have that
with porn why do you go our kids are
learning that this is normal and like
we'll tell them it's not them you know
they don't they don't play video games
and they think you know oh yeah I'm just
gonna go rob someone's car and run a
bunch of people over so
I started webcaming and it was really
fun it was like this there's something I
mean firstly you can have actual
conversations rather than sort of
posting a comment and then waiting for a
reply like it's just you know a chatroom
and then I just I really managed to sort
of open up a little bit through webcam
and just learn to be more confident and
be just it was it felt like at the end
of the day come online and I'd be
talking to my friends and it was just
really sweet and you also make money
from it and that was really great like
it's it's it's embarrassing to say but I
made just as much from camming and in a
lot less time than I was working with
three jobs I was at the time so it was
very it made a lot of sense for me then
to sort of go okay well I'm gonna quit
my three jobs and just do we're coming
for a bit and I didn't really have a
plan on what to do after that but it
seemed like a good way to save up money
and I thought well I could make a video
I've got nothing against that you know
you're kind of seeing me on cam anyway
I'm kind of doing all these sort of sexy
things but I didn't want to just sell it
off and then not know what people did
with the videos I mean though I I guess
I quite like the idea of having more
control over it which is why I thought
I'd start a website and I had a friend
at the time who sort of also was
thinking along the same things he's a
tech person but he was just he just went
like oh hey Harriet how about starting a
porn site together and I'm like hey yeah
that totally works though it's totally
Eliza know what I'm doing and I don't
think either of us would it be anything
big I think we're just like gonna sort
of do it for a laugh almost and then it
kind of got really popular and I guess
it just exploded from there I mean if
you had asked me when I was coming like
oh do you think you're going to be
running you know one of the UK's biggest
independent porn sites I'd be like get
out of here
so it kind of snowballs in
[Music]
here's the thing I do porn and I shoot
porn the way I like to have sex and
personally I'm a very vanilla person so
that's why my corns very vanilla I don't
get off on being called a [ __ ] or a
horse so I don't have that in my video
but I don't do that from a sense of you
know moral superiority or ethical
superiority I simply do that because
it's what I like and I really respect my
friends who are into BDSM or they work
at kink and they have this thing because
that's what they like and I think that's
what point should be about you do what
you like you do what you're comfortable
with and you do what get you off and as
for bringing kids into this right the
the narrative there shouldn't be oh I'm
doing this and it's great for kids to
watch because it's not kids should not
be watching it but it's not like oh my
phone's better than their porn it's very
much when you grow up there is a stage I
think everyone goes through it whether
late or early in life where you start
discovering what you like in sex you
don't discovering what your turns on are
and then pawn shouldn't be a way to
teach you that point should just be a
way that if you want to masturbate if
you want to have something you already
know what you like or you can find out
what you like and the options are there
if that makes sense
porn isn't a guide but porn isn't a way
to teach people it's more like you know
oh today I feel like eating sushi
there are sushi restaurants available oh
I feel like eating pizza there's heaps
are available it's more like that does
that make sense that's that is how I see
it
so yes the stuff I do is very very
vanilla very intimate and very happy
because that's just that's just what I
like and I only want to film what I'm
comfortable with you know that I have
people asking me like why haven't you
done a gangbang I'm like I wouldn't do
that in my personal life so I'm not
gonna do it on porn and because I own
and direct and produce my own stuff I
can make that choice which I'm very
happy about
[Music]
[Music]
there's this weird feeling that you
don't want like I'm not sure how to say
it but before I think I was very
defensive in general I think I made
myself unapproachable and I think I was
just automatically quite defensive and
aggressive and it's it's very hard to
admit that but it's what I was doing and
since you know becoming more confident
becoming just a little bit more curious
and adventurous and just sort of going
you know what I'm gonna try this I'm
gonna do this I'm gonna talk to these
people in real life and yeah learning to
say what you want learning to ask for
what you want in all aspects of your
life is such is so amazing and it's such
a good freedom and it's something you
really do have to learn and obviously it
definitely improves your sexuality
because being able to tell your partner
like oh I like doing this or oh I really
want to try that that obviously makes
things better I think a lot of people
find it still very difficult to tell
someone if they're not enjoying
something sexually because at the same
time you don't want to offend your
partner and maybe you think oh what if
they think of what I want to do is
really weird or really freaky so it is
it that if there is a hurdle there that
I think is really amazing if you can get
over it
progression wise I'm naturally moving
and learning new skills and at the
moment the business side of the things
is really interesting to me and really
motivating I want to focus on that I
still do the porn because I enjoy it and
you know it's really fun but there will
be a point where I'm like that I don't
really feel this with this one way or
another about it and when it gets to
that point I don't think I'll do it
because I don't want to do it unless
it's something that I truly enjoy and
get pleasure from
[Music]
you